hello there reject nation
I'm Greg Alba I'm John Humphrey we're
gonna watch pokemon rusty the complete
journey every episode no idea what this
is
top reward to your request from a man
named Melvin Eckstein let's just go into
it let's see what's in store for us
today pipes
[Music]
look out world today's the day I become
a pokemon trainer what
absolutely not rusty but dad it's my
destiny no your destiny is to go to
college and get a real job mister your
mother and I didn't bust our humps work
and seem to be some kind of professional
pet owner Red's mom lets him be a
trainer who is ready oh he's an awesome
trainer from Pallet Town like follow his
Twitter
you're always going on about this Pallet
Town what's wrong with Bay's town we're
not even on the map dad I'm 10 years old
I'm an adult I could go wherever I want
legally gasps that is true you're living
under my roof Buster you're gonna stay
here and help that with the Dell now
deliver this chicken panini to the
professor's house then go to school it's
just down the block from Bob it's
literally the only other house in town
God oh hey rusty that way lunch
professor tree you know a lot about
Pokemon right no really smooth just
easiest grant to apply for I got a
monthly paycheck in a free lab it's
kinda crowing I could spend the rest of
my time growing pot should told you that
I'm pretty high so you need someone to
go out and study Pokemon for you yeah
awesome
oh now 30 begins I'll take this kikuna
that's my first book came of it
wow you're good at this I thought that
was a paperweight you and me kikuna
we're gonna catch a ball so hello
professor tell my parents are dead
rusty wait you took my panini whoa two
piggies a new record Oh
I wonder how Reds pokémon journey is
going just a step battle with my rival
blue got a catchy mole dog horse
I need a rival to drive me to be the
very best nice I choose You Pikachu
that's a Kakuna great job Pikachu
classic rival move can't admit when he's
defeated we are not rivals anymore
I'm good home guess that means it's just
you and me other guys Pikachu I believe
it a pokemon trainer
Tuesdays and I've already defeated all
my rivals watch me to catch a few more
Pokemon and we'll be ready to take on
the champion I can look like one basic
you dream of this day
Oh Team Rocket Oh No are they going to
bets in here what kind of trainer would
I be if I didn't catch them all well
well well
no do you think you're going kid this is
Team Rocket turf we're an international
crime syndicate that steals Pokemon and
oh god here take them take them all Wow
usually that's way harder thanks you're
a real coward that's Mike Fergus or he's
super rare I think I got the first one
ever I'm pretty sure this is a Bulbasaur
with a birth defect what else does he
have pretty impressive huh I was out of
pokeballs I mean what do you want me to
do not catch every producer I see we
need to get these guys to focus enter
dumb monster let's grab this cocoon and
get out of here no Pikachu
oh my god it evolved out of pure
happiness the second I touched it what
did you do to this thing he could chew
he will fall to save me quick help me
out of here oh it's okay Beedrill you're
safe now come on let's go set the
Hospital on fire yeah all right rusty
things look bad but you can do this for
pete's sake rusty how could you just run
off like that take care of myself dad
why are you so worried there are
mobsters everywhere and professor tree
told us you were dead now as soon as we
get home you're gonna give up on your
dreams and study for the continue my
quest no hospital please well team
rocket burned down the only hospital but
I know another place that can heal you
Oh God
there's something I gotta take care of
first
can you catch you in your pokeball week
it gets Camrys okay here are you Pokemon
hey wait you forgot one huh well let's
see what's inside
how is he Nathan I I don't know want me
to rescue Pikachu for Team Rocket only
some serious equipment we're talking
ultra balls mega Candy's Buster Sword
it's your customized stationery I'll
take all of it what does it do you send
it to your friends yeah great where do I
catch friends step on is for all the
latest trainer fashion and accessories
no thanks I'm working the classical read
look you've probably heard of him he's
got two badges oh those duds are so last
gen Oh
about scarfs and hot pants now that
sounds really dumb let's take a break
for my Snorlax and this one only works
at noon on Sundays it's called a brunch
ball Wow it's like an evolution for my
feet excuse me Jackie I'll take this
bike cycle please that'll be a million
dollars Wow must be a legendary bike
well it is one-of-a-kind it's reserved
for a very special customer I'm special
that's me do you take dad's credit cards
did you see this Cinnabon possum can't
stay and talk professor I'm on my way to
save Pikachu hi I'm the guy who's
supposed to buy a bicycle filled of weed
oh oh you were gonna think this is real
funny sold it to a child what rusty
reminds me of a mint from the way
Wooper notes a tree give up and go home
what you need is an hm
they can teach your Pokemon secret moves
to overcome obstacles I've spent 60
years
oh you mean these yeah my mother bit
kiosk in the ball oh well guess I'll
just go to the mall then 60 years know
just the move to beat my new rival this
tree all right you time to learn
strength to life beautiful huh okay boys
stop throw me over okay use fly to carry
me Oh huh all right what do you think
kids pastor work watch your bug use
flash in a Lapras bro
okay too bad number seven time for us to
learn how to surf these gems aren't
working right - here
Mike showers ours flamethrower really
cuts through the competition that's it
[Music]
yeah
rusty no no yeah no duh your zubats
nature's friggin garbage no I'm an Eevee
trainer man it's like a super secret art
that's only for true a Pokemon masters
whoa you must have so many badges Oh
badges are for scrubs dude I played
independent tournaments the most
exclusive toy sores and middle school
gymnasiums no wonder your cough area
looks so buff a regiment of stat
boosting vitamins got it those only work
for the first 100 TVs
then you need a macho brace idiot or you
even writing this down you turn what
does Eve we're gonna be here for a while
[Music]
now you know all of my secrets Wow no no
that's not it like fun oh is it a poke
fun it's about that yeah meaning it's
good job you don't get paid for your
friggin dingus you don't wait a minute
that's just cool I can become a pokemon
trainer to learn my far-fetched
multiplication tables but then I'm
afraid you'll never have a Pokemon as
cool and strong
Team Rocket oh wait a minute
follow Team Rocket I can rescue Pikachu
see you later boring guy wait oh dude
you forgot to rain subscribe a how-to
videos
[Music]
bad market
[Music]
continues 17 get ready to lose old man
I'm here to earn my first badge first
this is Cinnabar Island most people have
a few badges under their belt before
they get here why are you wet
a trail Team Rocket of the SSM but I got
kicked off because I didn't have a
ticket so it's straight after them
well that's round then oh come on the
beach s when your gym and do that before
tests need you to feed you so let's
fight sure I kinda have to it's my job
[Music]
I've got just the pokeball to cool you
off like no no I'm the fire guy right
like that's my thing and ice is the
opposite of fire watching is the rarest
candy at all you get all these types
work now hmm this making sense children
oh yeah this is a special badge the
participation bag
I'll call you a water-taxi
who's real not an any Pokemon game I
look great job of the streamers Ted Wow
thanks Ron but tonight's not about
streamers you dick it's about the new
members of our family so true hey what's
your name again Russell Reginald okay I
can't read your nametag it looks like
you wrote a bunch of names and cross
them out I'm not at all rusty you guys
still Pikachu and I'm here to rescue him
what was your plan I was gonna defeat
each of you sequentially and Pokemon
battles and then you'd give up and give
me my podium on back and maybe like
somebody or something Wow don't plan
Tony killer Pikachu
you've come to save me well careful God
no wait this is your beak oh that's the
most sociopathic cruel and hateful
Pokemon we've ever seen how did you
train such concentrated evil traitorous
black hearted is you always has a place
of Team Rocket what do you say thanks
but I'm not a criminal
Oh guys check this out he spikes full of
drugs
[Music]
Wow so you just drive around give you
money people they sure do and if they
don't we burned down their homes and
businesses
okay here's your first assignment steal
that kids okay this time I'll show you
how it's done
oh god yeah oh oh come here you you're
gonna do it shampoos all right now you
try robbing that guy
excuse me sir prepare for rusty and make
it rusty mister
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow what a great day
[Music]
you are truly Wow yeah let's go
[Music]
[Music]
that's you you never got into you
necessary to the last or Beyblade you
versus the battle house wait listen kid
this thing cost me Millions
I'm in deep to Team Rocket and their new
boss is calling in death
I need the insurance around Dunsparce
but rusty loves battle house we've all
got our own battles kid besides don't
you wanna weigh them we are do great
work today pika - OH
[Music]
did you gain a little yet no you dropped
Ripa to five thirty seconds ago also it
was on fire
yeah so that horse is on fire that's
different for reasons I cannot explain
okay I remember you you're that boring
the EEV trainer that learned a lesson
oh I'm just here to pick up my Pokemon
and oh would you look at that they're
pulling it in right again Julian there
you go
oh yes every you're a breeding like
partner creating another perfect oh
c'mon oh yeah it's easy if you're not a
total Chara [ __ ] it just takes you
Pokemon is compatible at groups you know
how do you make a baby you know the UH
copies Oh less sigh if I want to make a
new Pikachu great Pikachu
there's an electric mouse which means
he's obviously in the field every no
Pikachu is my Beedrill he died the car
fire which you don't have a Beedrill
either no so what do you have but herbs
we shall crack good working for you as
you can see that bench my kiddos with
your reduced according to Ivy's you
should have a shiny badge with an
additive nature in just two thousand
seven hundred and thirty one has begun
to hatch
are they breeding dinners uh-huh-huh
I shall be Merkel if a Valentine after
the woman of our dreams
[Music]
look I told you this guy makes the best
buck fairies know what I want to go back
to Team Rocket yeah we the one to either
whoever says the new boss to go where
memberships at an all-time high
quit presenting exposition Dennis great
that sexy baby
[Music]
[Music]
they do all right
[Music]
all right pokémon tower all right this
is the perfect place to catch ghost
folks sure this place is like insanely
evil and haunted JK just have fun but be
careful you don't want to be coming
ghost Pokemon yourself
[Music]
oh excuse me wouldn't even by being
captured you're terrible sir we've been
waiting for you to come here
oh the Pokemon whose lives you beg keep
training no give up go home you were
born to work in a deli you're trying to
plug the drain wow you're a buddy boy
let's get you cleaned up and see what's
under there whoa grab on Crispin but
your [ __ ] oh right ghost thing I know
they're all upset Rusty's good boy sure
made mistakes
but these 10 is barely old enough to
smoke it's our job and it's never going
to use this
come on documentary here buddy
rusty what are you doing here professor
tree I didn't know you were a fan of her
yeah that's right now--get runs this
place
watch it Pokemon nature documentary in
the back can i watch have a seat TV in a
while because I sleep in the woods no
will they have enough snacks for the two
of us I have nine Pringles this rusty
Pringles what's up gringo it's starting
bro
some loud okay mom they're all around us
yeah little about them very little oh my
goodness just what they look more in hey
this one for instance looks like a human
[Music]
yeah we see a rare courtship display
between two okay
[Music]
all costs
[Music]
[Music]
and watch them once you pop oh yeah tray
excuse me sir
oh hello unattended child the old
parents know that you were alone in this
very room now papa this tiny balla do
what I say forever
okay kid you safe now tracking his
crooked fee drill for a while although
we can't legally prosecute a Pokemon so
we still need to find his master oh
that's me
rusty hi rusty oh great that was easy
forever get one of those Oh rusty spray
[Music]
it's gonna be the most intense episode
you're rusty this good since I killed my
old lady to celebrate thanks hard Rick
what if I wanted to serve that he's a
worse man I'm just at home I'm destined
to become a pokémon master
Oh or start your own daily hate cold
cuts my dream is to be the world's best
trader come on oh just like the one on
easy traders drive to 18 and up
deviantART page it's a sign I have
searched for you for so long father
please tell me what is my purpose
oh my um my purpose is to beat the Elite
Four that is my goal as well come father
let us become the best like no one ever
was
I'm gonna call you peanut butter come on
what are you waiting for
scripture more murders for us thanks
rusty rusty
as rusty my favorite I sure do peanut
butter come here boy
behold all the badges in Kanto from any
traders who help them you only needed
eight why would they covered in peanut
butter maybe close my Pokemon are pretty
low risk now brother I shall bear this
burden they do you're on the elite for
now congratulations please don't kill us
we're all happy and the lies let's
resume our meeting we were discussing
educational district rezoning cool yeah
huh my battle bad rusty were the elite
for the highest branch of government
sometimes I have to address issues other
than poking well you do have a scary
magic murder but dude we should probably
update the Pokedex for that is it a new
legendary Oh Daniela I'm not done
legendary come on Phoebe I live only to
sleep your blood thirst father on the
way out I've been eating at a draught
pants for a year
someone should probably tell her family
okay not it not damaged Oh
oh my gosh peanut butter it's a
legendary quick use uh-oh what do you
know again this busy wandering the woods
unattended woods no this is the safari
zones legendary pokémon preserve welcome
back to your tour I'm Safari Marge on
our left are some elemental birds and on
our right are just so many fairy babies
safari zone is where you pay money to
throw rocks at kangaroos oh that's just
the business side we're all so uh nature
preserve how are you able to capture
these powerful godlike creatures
legendary Pokemon aren't gods they're
legendary because they're super
endangered look Sam I don't posters hung
veggie berries because they think
they're magic but in reality they're no
different than any garden-variety fire
horse or psychic duck if we don't take
care of them it'll go extinct like
dinosaurs dogs
I miss the hooks everyone misses dogs
but these poor legionaries could never
survive outside these walls see over
there
not a single mouse or foot I don't know
what kind of God made that but he was
clearly running out of ID
I'm going to grind you up and sub you
the wall morning Carlos businessman what
did I say about pochi today I've
discovered my true opponent mankind's
greed and it is super effective father I
have learned compassion but I already
know for me it's boring forget that it
is forgotten I would also like to learn
thirst for vengeance oh no I know sort
of paperwork for me indeed for the
ledger of my people must be balanced
first see where this is going
Oh Louis to be the dark Harold yes a
dark breeze blows this day I thought my
purpose to serve but now I see it is to
I will bear this world out of the age of
man and into the a on of dude might be
my crew doing everything I say I love
how we finish each other sentences
full-time slave buddy
what a cool room hey wait a minute I
know you guys Eevee trainer professor
tree sexy berry I say one piece kept
doing here let's read assemble all the
world's top Pokemon experts into a
single unified resistance this is all
your fur we need you to stop you
according to our top and only scientist
so everything bad that has ever happened
to anyone is your fault I'm captured
dialga and uses power to create time
machine and sandwich don't listen to
anyone but yourself you it's the only
way perfect so good it's my job to save
the world
wait yep was working the deli till you
die and that makes me a great trainer
trust me sandwiches like no one ever was
a tree which is why you to convince your
past self to give up on streams doesn't
work on the demo yeah I already did that
um what with last time wait a minute wow
you're really rusty we already sent back
in time did Y all still follow me
somebody I think I'm the world's
greatest pokémon trainer wouldn't pick
you up in a crash in the store laughs I
think it's time to finally my destiny
[Music]
Oh oh come on I help be
[Music]
very curious to see yeah sweet George's
he duped Steve on this can't get any
worse this is one world we can't win
rusty tell my wife I said get me so
cheap that spark this and send me to my
grave on a cottony cloud of world-class
primo mega deck come father at long last
be one with the deuce Oh God what's
happening to me
I feel bad and this is why folks for the
first time I feel almost not the best oh
my god can't be rusty alert it with thee
I know what I have to do
[Music]
you literally just tried that you know
what I'm making your skin up that
ring-a-ding-ding sorry your taters have
doorbell for door so I left myself in
any way special delivery for the anti to
do persistence farce [ __ ] that's the
party platter bar order
honestly we thought this day was gonna
go way differently oh hey it's future me
help me fulfill my destiny yet girl no
go back home daily rusty you're so
annoying
wait your bag it smells delicious this
this is the best thing I've ever tasted
so simple yet so elegant
thank you good rusty you've shown me
that there is hope very inside even the
worst of humanity yeah bird
rusty journey the Stars on search of the
hope surely also on bringing this sexy
berry now wait just one word a minute I
want to go on space adventures to worry
not that rusty I have a reward suited to
your talents as well yeah can't bust the
rough t-shirt I always wear my jacket
canonically ready my sweet sandwich
Prince if I ever did we shall depart and
as a token I should undo all my do flee
deeds the world shall be as it was
all sciences that you forget enough
faded and Kanto is at peace once more
in other news a local deli is serving up
a customers call the perfect sandwich
stay tuned for more after that
oh here you go sir one rusty special
thanks kid you really found your
potential now face forth to take orders
what did I ever do to deserve this the
old rusty the galaxy is full of wonders
we River fluffy
[Music]
who genius this was magical this was
pretty pretty pretty magical
[Music]
this is the greatest thing that's ever
gone up on YouTube it's better than the
history of the entire world
[Music]
all right second to history in turn I
could actually keep up with this yes
yeah tells the sensical story by the end
[Music]
Mikey's illustrations too at the end
Giulia slaughter that's a cool name
what is this channel Dorothy Dorothy
Dorothy I have hit the notification bell
on them oh look out I will watch so many
of their videos now yeah spend an hour a
day catching up with all their various
nerdy scenes was incredible let's review
it I thought this was really really
really well done it started off in a way
where I was like okay it's just gonna be
a bunch of bits it's gonna be you know
which is like ah we're gonna make fun of
Pokemon a person I had to like adjust to
it because I was thinking oh is this
from the actual game and just doing a
voiceover then but didn't take long to
me to realize like oh wait no it's
actually all animated and they they just
did it in the style of how the Pokemon
game looks i wasn't like an avid you
know Pokemon game player 4 on Gameboy
like I played it but it wasn't like
addicted to 8 this wasn't really built
into like my nostalgia for it cuz I have
the show that I grew up on that's for my
nostalgia for Pokemon comes in but I
thought the animation for it was it was
really really well done the commitment
to reminded me of like South Park level
of humor at first it starts off thinking
that yeah it's just a bunch of like
random bits but then really early on I
started going oh wait a minute there's
gonna be like a character arc here if
there's gonna be a story that's gonna I
love that element to it cuz it easily
could have just been something medicine
you know parroting Pokemon just for the
people that have played the games as
well it has some of those jokes in there
like I love the joke about and they're
watching the documentary like these are
just Birds you know and they make fun of
stuff here and there throughout the game
but I think even if you're not into the
game you can still enjoy this like crazy
Adventure and watching this character
who doesn't realize how they just keep
doing just flat-out [ __ ] up things
assistant Lee all comes crumbling by the
end and I love how everything comes back
around to I think is this is a story
it's really well done it's more than
just funny to me it was kind of I was
really impressed with how it all came to
an ultimate culmination by the end of it
all yeah it made me really wonder how
this show unfolded to begin with because
this is a compilation of all the
episodes and at one point they do point
out why how would any of this
time-travel stuff work with this horror
well continuity so I almost wonder if
they started off with just a funny
little idea that eventually grew into
something much much bigger because it's
nice that this is totally in the know
but because rusty is such an idiot you
don't have to be in the know to enjoy it
because it's just about this guy failing
upward and like you kind of learn the
world in and of itself and I feel like
it rides with a lot of just jokes that
you would make if you just heard about
Pokemon yeah you know bellies like ten
year old kids just like imprisoning
these animals and like leaving home and
going out into the world to have them
have actual parents and stuff well I
love the the effect that it has on
everything that goes on like it's like
surprisingly character-driven and
well-thought-out with the Beedrill how
it comes out for being a cocoon that I
love that joke about yeah by different
Pikachu in Turkey but have a B trill it
becomes this like gym leader monster and
even things that you think are throwaway
ultimately come back though the peanut
butter character yeah you know I think
there's just a bit that's all right
there we did that bit now we're over it
but if that even comes back yeah this is
a weird reoccurring joke of he's 10
years old he's it and don't you see he's
barely oh I have a very soft spot in my
heart for like well-thought-out stupid
stuff yeah and this is kind of a great
example of that as like rusty is such an
idiot and the fun is watching him fail
upward in the most ridiculous ways to
have him spawn both the worst possible
and arguably like the best possible
Pokemon the course of this is pretty
funny it was make you feel like another
dudes like Pokemon Cinematic Universe
right now after that the success of
detective Pikachu and I wish they would
avenge
you're into something like this story
yeah honestly I think they'll be really
cool and do you do well it's nothing
more than to be a pokemon trainer but
it's not destined why are you not
pointing she's ruining everyone's life
rent because you Potter died while we
were doing a reaction it reminds you
like Emmet from the lego movie
he's just considered a bad guy he's even
called bad rusty but dad you know let's
could have just been something that it
relies on just a bunch of cheap jokes
and vulgarity but it's not it's more
than that this is an actually really
like rich story that you get here yeah
well and it unfolds in a way that you
just don't see coming you can feel that
sort I don't remember exactly who wrote
all this but you can feel that level of
would it be funny if this happened this
happened then this happened but it's
also very inventive I mean I love the
way that they realized the animation too
cuz I couldn't tell through this if this
was based on I mean it's obviously based
on some of the you know video games and
whatnot but I couldn't tell if some of
these sets and some of these locations
were ripped directly or something like
that because when I played you know a
Pokemon game like this it was a little
less advanced but yeah just seeing them
jump between the different like I'm
gonna name them wrong but you know eight
16-bit 32-bit looking animations and
stuff like when they're watching the
nature documentary the animation is that
much nicer but in a still geometric
blocky kind of way yeah the different
earmarks that make this feel weirdly
lived in when it starts out like yeah
professor of tree is smoking a bong in
the first episode but like as I remember
the start of the story it felt kind of
plucky and innocent and then they
gradually add more and more messed up
things yeah because as he becomes bad
rusty the the feared rusty he's he's
never intentionally doing any of that
he's so naive so interested he has no
idea he's doing any of it to the very
end of it all yeah of like did I deserve
this but even there's a little bit of an
arc where he learns empathy you know and
I love that too that he goes back he
does the thing he realizes the purpose
but then it completely on doesn't by
going well someone had to become the
best trainer just completely reliving
his destiny completely missing the point
at all turns and that's why I guess yeah
this this does I think a perfect way to
describe the sensibility of this is like
it has that Lego movies
deconstructive irony with that Southpark
sense of wacky bass yeah it's already
yeah and and you know some of the voices
very much the one trainer guy sounded
exactly like a South Park carry yes
weird you know we pronounce a thing no
the professor treated yeah that's a tree
well this came out in 2017 I'm assuming
sometimes in this man it's 2016 to 2017
in total this is incredible thank you
guys for putting this together Thank You
Melvin Ickx
for baby nose world who have expanded
our minds into something amazing I am
dead tired right now yet this was so
easy to stay away from 47 minutes more
and enjoy this this is the fastest I
finished a series in long yeah that
feels good to complete a whole show yeah
so Thank You Melvin X for being so kind
of being at our patreon page for such a
long time and barely asking for anything
in return
you're the best guys so make sure to
subscribe to dorkly subscribe to us
click the notification bell we'll catch
you guys soon this is awesome thank you
I choose you Jews